so I thought the film was really
entertaining there are a lot of big
action-packed moments put some really
nice tender moments as well um I have to
ask what was it like working with not
one but three giant CGI animals well one
of them was really fun
because George was played by an actor
called Jason Lisle so we had a lot of a
lot to kind of react to and a lot of he
gave us a lot of emotion and so on and a
lot of humor as well so that was great
but the other two were just tennis balls
wow that was it tennis balls on sticks
that's all we had to go off and that was
tough because you have to just use your
imagination thankfully our director brad
peyton he's an amazing painter so he did
these sketches of what the creatures
were going to look like but having them
on a bit of paper this size it's not the
same as seeing them like how ginormous
and they're amazing on screen as well I
like the flames a little bit Scottie
she's really witty and she's got really
nice heart and was she quite an
enjoyable character to play yeah she
really was I loved the fact that she's
badass as well you know I love the fact
that she's also really brave she's kind
of like okay I feel responsible for this
virus situation so I'm gonna dive right
in there and put my life at risk and go
you know try and save the world because
it's totally different to me I'd be
staying at home hi date obviously really
production was a lot of stunts did you
have to go undergo any special training
or let up your workouts which ii thought
so i did up my workouts and i did sort
of work with a lady who actually
prepared me for the Bond franchise so I
worked with her for a month before when
but I might as well have not bothered to
be honest because it was not anything to
do with stunts they really no it wasn't
it wasn't stuff that I could train for
it was things like being strung up to
the ceiling on wires and being on a
plane replica plane tilted at 90 degrees
and having to swing from one side of it
to the other and and crawl along with a
wind machine
blowing in your face and things like
that really so I guess my workout really
helps but it wasn't those kind of stunts
like in bonds or what-have-you it wasn't
like that and then it was a lot of a
green-screen stunts like in the
helicopter and so on um I think rampage
is actually quite an inspiring film kind
of makes you want to get outta bed and
go and save the world even your life
inspires you the most I would say my mum
inspires me the most I think you know
she she had me when she was 18 years old
so she was very young and she raised me
on her own and despite you know we
didn't come from money at all but
despite that my mom always taught me
that anything is possible and I can
achieve anything that I put my mind to
and I really I'm just so grateful to her
for that
um as an actress you obviously do a lot
of traveling there's a lot of long days
do you have any wellness hacks that you
absolutely swear by oh my god so many so
many so I feel like waking up before
6:00 a.m. is really important and that's
really important because it's good to
wake up with the Sun and I find like the
longer I stay in bed the more kind of
sleepy I am and throughout the day I
mean and then also it means that I have
a carve out time for myself to kind of
do my routines which are I like to do a
bit of exercise to get my heart rate
pumping nothing like Duane's where he's
two hours in the gym and then I also
meditate and then I do my morning pages
as well so I just kind of write whatever
comes into my head kind of my mini diary
and that's a real great way of like
things that I'm uncomfortable with or I
need to sort of dissect in my mind I get
them on the page and it really helps me
love to know which beauty products could
you absolutely not live it out I think
the biggest one from his cleanser so
many of my friends like go to sleep with
their makeup on and I'm like it was
really bad so I would I have to have
cleanse I have to cleanse my face and
especially after you know day like this
with so much makeup in front of Cameron
lion
you know yeah is there a specific brand
that you love or I love the organic
pharmacy
I love environ as well and a big fan of
environment there's my two favorite
amazing yeah well thank you very much
for your time thank you